you guys have such great chemistry as
mother and daughter in this and um i
wanted to know rosalie as someone who is
new to this industry did you have any
good advice from sandra when it comes to
working in the industry and did you take
anything away for future projects
oh i mean unfortunately we didn't
actually work next to each other in the
booth we were all recorded separately
and i only i only met sandra in person
um at the beginning of the press tour
but i would say that
the thing that sandra has told me that i
feel like
i tell her to eat
i tell her to sleep yes yes uh and teach
her to you know if there's a question
that you do not want to answer don't
answer it that takes a lifetime to learn
and also so i basically take her teacher
wellness
how to take care of herself yes yeah
oh i know something that you've said
many times was to be kind to yourself
yeah i feel like as a teenager i can be
quite self-deprecating i know it's so
difficult it's really really difficult
and i think sandra just taught me to
love myself
yeah for sure and sandra i mean i've
been in love with your work for many
years i can't wait for uma um
this feels like a very personal story
and i feel like a lot of asians can
relate to the story that's being told
here in turning red um playing ming
did you ever feel like it was did you
ever reference things that felt close to
your own life like when it came to
portraying this character this mother
figure
oh i'm sure yes meaning like
not only as asian americans everyone but
i will be specific about asian americans
uh
[Music]
our mothers can be tough every mother is
tough
but our mothers can be tough and the
desire to
please them
uh and the difficulty of of finding
yourself while maintaining loyalty
um is is really real um so it was a
great uh opportunity just to be able to
put that on screen i will say one of my
favorite not to give too much away but
one of my favorite images that actually
brought tears to my eyes is the moment
that may as a panda is trying to leave
um the temple and her mother and her
aunties and her grandmother are all
trying to hold her back
that's i fee i feel so deeply as an
asian american like the tie between the
people who really love you who want you
to stay
and your deep need to go
um and i i'm so happy that that image is
a part of the the film yeah i agree and
i i think i really appreciate you being
so vocal when it comes to asian activism
and speaking up for the community i
wanted to know um what do you hope for
this younger you know new generation of
asian talent like rosalie um who are
coming into this area this this industry
that's you know being flooded with new
faces uh what do you what do you hope
for them
what i hope for
yeah is that um that there's space and
patience and time to develop
you know what i mean this is this is a
real nice good beginning time for us
where there are more stories that are
ready to be told uh and i really feel in
the asian american community
storytelling wise acting wise and all in
all
and all branches we need time to
continue to develop
um and uh and i'm just thrilled i'm just
thrilled that there's a space for them
amazing well i really want to thank you
guys for talking with me and i can't
wait for everybody to see the film i
laughed i cried it was a whole thing
good thank you so much for speaking with
me thank you
you